[Music]
in shitty day news submitted by ready
for summer a cereal dine and dash dater
has been leaving women with the
restaurant bill for at least three years
what a genius that's like every day in
Los I know there's much really well I
feel like I pay for until I dated Steve
huh until I started dating Steve I I
paid for like all the dinners or we
split we split seeded I'm so glad
there's equality finally yeah right I
was never equal to me I was the one I
was paying no I mean you're doing it for
a woman kind of a woman Kyra's Olaf how
do you end up paying for how does it go
they're like well we I don't have any
money so Leslie I don't want to I don't
want to go out cuz I go out so I'll pay
for it like you were inviting them yeah
because like they wouldn't go out with
me but even on the first date Thursday
no she's the one that's inviting them
because humor Chili's deal I guess what
a lot of comedians they're very poor
that's comedians that also sell drugs on
the side so they have money there you go
you're a success I walked in now can't
do it yes this man here he's been
pulling this [ __ ] around LA and like her
own peasant maybe you dated him
probably yeah so the name is Paul
Gonzales is that ring a bell I did
Westsiders only what does that mean
she's a no Pasadena people she wouldn't
have to date this guy though because she
paid the bill he wouldn't have to -
that's true
he would just be chillin there this is
what he looks like
ok ok so he's been this guy's been
everywhere yeah for the last 3 years
yeah and they still haven't caught him
yeah well I mean doesn't he ever want to
get laid though like he doesn't want to
take it past the food to like hook up
that's a good question he's just trying
to kill his boy
saying that women will only have sex
with guys that paid the bill no I'm
saying that men only want to have sex
all the time
do you rather have food and sex I want
to have sex right in and right now in
this instant because I'm hungry what I'm
too hungry to have sex right now or
maybe he has his food [ __ ] and
[ __ ] maybe food [ __ ] and [ __ ]
you'd say no could that happen no and if
he's doing three dates a day he's not
gonna try to [ __ ] three times a day but
[Music]
maybe then he pays for the dinner one
maybe he has a girlfriend at home and he
goes on dates just to eat that's [ __ ]
up so the girlfriend never gets to eat
oh he's a job it's a really fun she
works at a restaurant so she gets free
meals okay yeah you really don't get hey
hey maybe he has a big appetite do
people who doesn't make enough to eat
enough you know I love that he's like
he's like he's like we should get some
ass you know what he does is he arrives
before the girl gets there he already
orders his food starts eating yeah that
rule gets there and then so like this
first one instance he excused himself to
go get a charger from his phone but they
never came back to cover the 130 dollar
bill this other occasion was he said
that he's he was waiting for a phone
call from his mom about his aunt and
that he had to leave or something I
don't know like I need to get with
stories from all these girls there's
like one girl yeah there's one girl find
out oh I dated that guy she live a
Facebook post and I just went viral yeah
no yeah so there's there have been
reports about this guy already and so
more women are coming forward but
they're not giving they're not
disclosing their last names a lot of
women are just really so embarrassed
they're embarrassed like to have gone
through with this so then a lot of them
don't really like get even usually for
my [ __ ] he used me for my money
that's even worse yeah and then like
it's just kind of humiliating to just
being sit there like being you got yeah
you got all dressed and ready to go on a
date and that's true if I was no and I'm
like yo I paid for the [ __ ] I'm getting
some [ __ ] dick exactly well and also
it's expensive makeup is expensive
getting your hair done is expensive
Gaza's except is expensive to upkeep
once you got stood up by real cutie I've
seen this [ __ ] happen like in person in
real life when I worked at a restaurant
oh really
yeah and it was like a group of guys
group of girls I guess they you know I
guess they got them on the streets and
they're like let's go hang out and let's
eat get a few drinks right so they're
chilling there and then the girls like
seemed kind of shy but they're laughing
they're having a good time and then one
by one the guys leave and then like the
girls are just waiting and they're just
like imagine being the last guy leaving
dead and in the manager how to come and
like talk to them and they're like yeah
someone's got to pay for it they're like
well we don't want it like this you know
they said they were gonna take care of
us and [ __ ] and then I was just in there
a group of [ __ ] douche bags all found
each other that's crazy yeah I was like
dad oh I felt bad for the girls man I
was like I ain't gonna pay for y'all but
I feel bad and I could pay and I could
do it easily and I wouldn't even sweat
but I'm not gonna do it thank you
oh you thank you I only dine and dash
once it was in junior high and there's
some Denny's and everyone was doing it
and I felt so bad after you know what's
sad about it isn't Albert at Chili's and
if we had a walkout we got dinged for it
yeah they would they would write us up
and if you get too many write-up so
you're fired too many people walk out on
your like even though because they
should yeah you should have been
watching your customers more but if
you're slammed which is when they walk
out they don't walk out when you're
there yeah that's why I felt bad about
that public I was being like this sneaky
coward like if I wanted to rob someone I
should rob them in their face yeah I
gotta look good man with honor [ __ ]
give me your [ __ ] tips yeah honorable
you and even use a gun either hey don't
put the gun in my back pal
you put it right in my [ __ ] face like
a man
yeah that's true that's so crazy also
people that don't tip with [ __ ]
if you don't tip the server gets dinged
from their paycheck because the
government already assumes that you're
getting at least 10 percent of your
sales so if you don't claim to have at
least 10 percent of each check as your
tip they do they automatically take it
out of your paycheck so when people are
like oh they're already getting paid
like why do they why would we need a tip
like they already do they do your job
you don't tip my accountant or whatever
the [ __ ] it's like know that they
already the government already assumes
you're getting tips what if my tip is
valuable life advice like get a higher
paying job and I write that on the
receipt they have leave a q-tip or
something yeah
rib tips or what have you religiously
don't believe in tips really that's fine
you're a dick like your religion is a
dick like a Jedi right they don't
believe in tips ins yeah they don't
believe in love wow you're so good you
just say Jedi yeah in Australia there's
actually a group that like a sizeable
chunk like it's 4% or something that
call themselves Jenner but they don't
believe in emotions either you can't
have attachments to your family or
you're so Jedi's don't have booty calls
yeah you don't get to have sex I don't
know why I think that they're just
trolls kook so when they cuz when they
write down their religious like you know
affiliation they sort of like other and
then you write Jedi yeah how about this
movie my boy the pasta variant yeah
that's a religion it's called a
Pastafarian pastafarian and then they
believe in that's like all the Satanists
like it's just trolling yeah one good
it's funny like whenever they're like we
want a Satan monument to go across the
street from the Christian Monument I
love all that I think it's hilarious
what if they were serious like they want
to actual statue of like or whatever the
[ __ ] that's what they wanted to do in
like North Carolina remember was it
North Carolina it was one of those
states but they wanted to put that
straight goat it was scary as [ __ ] like
next to all the the
god no one though yeah that's for the
wall no words for the lulz it really is
yeah I think one of the III think it's
sameness are the fake ones or the trolls
and then there's like the Luciferian or
whatever that is series applause the
fairies and Luciferian or something like
that barians got it because it's like
Rastafarians yeah what the hell is a
Rastafarian around so far that's the Bob
Marley one yeah you believe in Bob
Marley he owns that whole brand yeah
not crazy yeah you got a lock on a whole
brand ya know a whole genre of music
they imagine if everyone's like oh man
you're very Bar Quan like that's bark
want Jamal yeah it's like that's true
but it's a small country right now
through time we got a great growing mode
now you have a dog walker no no you can
be like one of those little towels that
you drop in the water and then because
the finder what glass of water like a
little dinosaur mm-hmm that is the one
of the most useless like after the fact
there's nothing to do with it that's
just chilling the whole value is in when
it's a pill form and turning into the
thing and that's the [ __ ] junk now
yeah what do people do with those cool
yeah that's it and then you and then you
get another one cool well back to the
dine and dash thing did you guys know
you can be jailed for up to six months
or fined up to $1,000 if you dine and
dash on a bill that was under 900 did
you get caught you did not dine in - you
did not - you just kind and crashed yes
right dine in catch dude he got catched
I actually watched this this news thing
on on this dine and dash sure he got
caught like a manager recognized them
but instead of calling the police and
all that [ __ ]
he just told him to leave yeah and then
told the girl about him after he left
yeah my dude yeah but like it could be
kind of like those shoplifting laws
where like if you get caught shoplifting
you can be jailed but
stores just like take your picture and
ban you from the store and like let you
go and they like don't ever you can't
ever shop the funny thing is I would
have called the police and be like oh I
got some more appetizer on the house
like I try to keep them there as [ __ ]
long as possible and in the cop
catechism but then it's a drag hot wing
in hand and yeah but then it's in
traveling right because you just you
just like ordered a bunch of is that
yeah you sent a bunch of [ __ ] out right
and then now you got to pay the bill for
all that [ __ ] laws [ __ ] suck it's
like you can't you can only do like like
you can only be so defensive before
becomes on the offense I don't like that
why can't you just kick someone's ass
yeah I mean yeah but you catch the most
because of assault
you [ __ ] yeah see like you that's a
law - yeah hate that [ __ ] yeah mm-hmm is
because no matter which way you go
there's people that abuse the law yeah a
barbarian barbarian like there were
people that be like oh he tried to die
in so dining - so I just beat him up but
really they didn't huh so what do you
feel - do you have to do like a
citizen's arrest just hug him until the
cops come I would love to do a video of
us just giving citizen's arrest so bad
I've wanted to do that forever
I like someone littered and we're like
citizen's arrest yeah you called 9-1-1
so we got a little bug here
it's like sir we're executing a
citizen's arrest you do need to be
immobile during this process you don't I
mean like like you have to talk like
like that yeah and like print out the
actual because there's a form like
really yeah I print out the actual phone
let's do this funny version of the
Miranda rights I think so we have to do
them their rights like you have to say
this is a citizen's arrest I'm making a
citizen's arrest like that kind of thing
citizen's arrest is there such thing as
citizen's arrest brutality get you far
cuz you're not supposed to put hands on
I'm right yeah but then you did make a
citizen's arrest and they didn't comply
oh yeah you that's what you have to give
them the resisting citizen's arrest slam
her head on the carpet yeah stop
resisting
[Music]
[Music]